ciao ragazzi ben trovati sul mio canale
oggi ho deciso di darmi all'arte al
disegno o qui il mio meraviglioso ipad
con tanto di apple pella e delle vostre
foto
la scorsa settimana infatti che ho
chiesto di postare sulle vostre stories
di instagram delle vostre foto
qualora aveste voluto un ritratto con
l'ashtag come le due ragazze francesi
alcune persone hanno colto diciamo la
citazione altre no bloccate subito che
altro detto ai di danni il consenso di
poterlo utilizzare in un video comunque
di poterci fare quello che volevo io
anche semplicemente stamparle usarle
come carta da parati per la mia
abitazione non potrà farle tutte per
questo mi dispiace ma cerchiamo di farne
il più possibile con loro che mi
verranno il tempo c'era un giudice molto
severo si tempo ha pero instagram avrò
inizialmente tre minuti tempo vediamo se
poi andremo a diminuire e vediamo un
pochino che cosa riuscirò a fare la
politica quotidiani è perché come le due
ragazze francese infatti non l'ho capito
quella battuta chiaramente caricature
sono cioè di non essere caricature non
posso fare una cosa seria
partiamo con la prima lei è felicissima
di essere una musicista a parte che una
frangia felicissima ma allora dove sta
francia se si ascoltiamo la musica
sembri di un'altra etnia specie di gote
super felici
mamma mia una vecchia o trasformata in
una vecchia sopracciglio sì c'era era
supercella ok e ai più trucco yeah
mamma mia che cosa gli è successo non mi
sono proprio finendo comunque fare molto
molto peggio sono d'accordo potrei fare
peggio non sono per niente la nostra
amica purtroppo è stato sfortunato a
prelà pure la prima 15 st andiamo con la
seconda che è lei in compagnia di un
uccello che ha una cresta che tipo di
tutto che allora questo va beh lei ce
l'ho no no vabbè ma posso cancellare o
no ti ho fatto una riminese
non puoi cancellare le ho fatto meglio
il piccione dell'epr e compare qui sotto
anche lei è un po di frangetta vero
mamma mia che sono sotto pressione lei
si aspettava un qualcosa di meraviglioso
subito che manca un minuto ma mozza
quanto si possa migliorare la situazione
4 3 2 1 scuro turci tempio scusa milano
non è così male adesso dobbiamo per
forza credi che questo è un buon modello
è un poi tirar fuori qualcosa di buono
innovativo e passano a mettere così
questa è molto difficile la dinamica di
questa foto lo farò mai chiare ed e
sognante oddio non sbaglia no no no no
no no no no no ragazzi sono bravo a
disegnare ovvio
qui subentra un piede mi spieghi come
fai ti ho fatto la verità giusto casi è
una gamba che esce e pro verso il cielo
e si sprigiona sembra che ho fatto e lo
zampone di un pulmino qua ti ma ha un
piede enorme un piede minuti mamma mia
cosa là sotto e stranissimo ma guarda
che anche nella foto e c'è qualcosa da
sotto che stranissimo mi dispiace
scusami ambiguo braccio sentisse è una
foto che però posso dirti è una delle
mie preferite complimenti artistica
circense contorsionisti caccia può io
forse sei tu lo sai o sei originale con
7 pisani è facile questa ti diamo due
minuti
no no no perché mi sono sempre tipo
drogate questo momento e calze esatte
v.no di casa sembrano le app posso
salvarti posso salvare mi sembra un
nuovo alle labbra molto carnose no vabbè
ragazzi perdonami se fosse così mi babbo
natale così il babbo natale ok audio
bose che tutto sommato 8 sommato ma
questa come denuncia questa povera
ragazza mi denuncia ma mi denuncia
glielo ha fatto fare a queste persone ha
mandati le foto non lo sa che guidavano
io mi sento di aver perduto traduce hai
fatto il biglietto di auguri del natale
è tutto tortorelli ma adesso più tempo e
ho tradito la vostra fiducia vi chiedo
scusa io ti do cinque player is a troppo
mascolina perché per il resto secondo me
era un buon lavoro è un buon lavoro
cosa ha detto tic un'idea credo che sia
la bomba che ci andiamo alla prossima
curavo che coraggio
c'è questa presenza di questo naso ma
puoi fare bene oddio no sembra un
castoro
non avrei mai voluto farti una cosa per
noi sembrano i disegni di kill bill di
giapponese vento perché non sta facendo
il doppio mento opposta lo vedi in odio
barba c'è la barbagia la barba ai 10
segua allora sembra un dito mi sono
lasciato trasportare dall ispirazione
artistica del momento perché comunque è
un tipo di tratto impressionistico
questo un sei e mezzo il 6 e mezzo io ti
do 6 forse meno andiamo avanti
complimenti voglio riuscire a prendere
la sua espressione e se riesci a fare la
bocca rossa vinci crediamo nel cose di
scovare un ti prego non di armi via ok
l'urlo di munch questi cimeli avvio ad
aggiustare le sopracciglia la famiglia
vedi che allarga le narici
oddio no però no
così larghe guerra espressione
gravissima c'è questa specie di rasata
di lato o qualche lentiggini nachino
dexter sinistra o niente non si riuscì
guarda con rosso avresti link e vabbè
però vuoi mettere che ho fatto lo
scarico per gianmarco io sto facendo mi
so preso due secondi darei un 3 e mezzo
davvero se io no 5 all'inizio era
partito bene e sopracciglia parte poi si
è perso
sono stufo di ricevere solamente
critiche dal genero e tre e mezzo lo
sguardo senini da primato si e mezzo ma
come fai a dare tremezzo e mezzo su
un'opera che vale non corre 4 meno e
proseguiamo di cellulare vanno a fare
questo non è fare però pure tu sotto
cose o due cose un altro 3 e mezza e
lasciva lei al giornale normale come
partenza inizia un pochino di rughe sul
mento per
[Risate]
devo crederci fino alla fine arrendermi
mai tutto bello poi ai teso fra ciglia e
mi potrei ritenere soddisfatto quasi
finire prima sentite dai ragazzi è
l'essenza che viene catturata di queste
persone l'anima la sufficienza l'è presa
con me dai 66 e mezzo ho sbagliato
qualche proporzione con il mento 5 meno
noti proprio no regata soddisfacendo la
vera guarda guarda il confronto però
alla preso ben l'anima posso no ma no
non è da sufficiente 6 meno io voglio
darti un bel voto ma devono sentire lui
devi convincere ma un rene
fra questi cani però assomigliano dei
pipistrelli prendiamo giorno col cane
che si può riferire figli lei che mi
entra come una monnalisa moderna veloce
veloce ora mi stai messo un occhio a
caso di scarto questo bel disegno su una
mia osceno il cane non benissimo creato
quasimodo a lei non ha mai fatto male ma
le sedi cento quindi che quasimodo a
questa qua ma che ti ha fatto il male
questa ragazza guarda se vende me e
anche se e mezzo io ti chiedo scusa
perché crede veramente da subito grande
ancora sia il loro sempre avanti tutti i
miopi siete vulcanico disegnare il cane
molto simpatico comunque dovere cioè
dicendo che lei antipatica no nel senso
quindi fanno troppo ridere i cani con
gli occhiali da sole
replicando sugli specchi e scusa il cane
non è quella destra
le grandi del 6 allegra o spiritato a
verona il mar delle labbra palla sto tra
disegnando e sembra mister potato no no
no ma no ma sembra in di norme scusami
adesso sembrato tokyo
mamma mia ragazzi ritorniamo delle
insufficienze 5
il cane è buono e meno non ci credo vedi
l'espressione che io credo che l'essenza
ci sia molto più alto dai ragazzi per
favore cioè devo stare a giustificare
spiegare la mia arte dami un questa
pappagorgia è stato un errore e gratuita
proprio una che gratuita non posso
cancellare porta io posso cancellare cap
6 nero
non voglio vedere stasera come dormire
sonni sereni e lo sta strozzando a
questo campo questi occhi dolci ma che
stai facendo sempre quello dei
disoccupati
mandai penna cioè ma sembrano senza te
rivedo madonella befana ma che stai
facendo il tuo cane che è diventato
cinese lo stringe forte a te hanno presa
ferrea in realtà un randagio questo cane
hanno sbagliato uno è che io ho capito
assomiglia all'amica di baffi io ti do
77 è facile alla faccia di lei malino
secondo me è una reinterpretazione cioè
il cane sta male in quel disegno anche
resta ho capito con quella foto ma messa
in un girone infernale
ok a 77 la mia opera migliore fino all
ultima disegno ragazzi se io mi sono
lamentato degli occhiali fino ad adesso
allena admob romagna contro una faccia
inespressiva e nell'intensità trova la
sua forma di espressione sembra
tristezza paio di occhiali sbagliate è
caronia per farti che lei in questo modo
a una fronte infinita
dovrò un pochino inventarmi quale
cosa qui ai suoi riccioli molto belli
facciamo continuo delle di livelli
perché comunque tanti capelli
ok eccola in ultimo disegno il migliore
secondo me questo per me è il migliore 8
in ritito otto e mezzo
noi bye bye chiudo con una media 8 otto
e mezzo ci ho messo il cuore
grazie queen of moscow mai regalato il
mio 88 e mezzo adesso vi faremo
velocemente vedere in sequenza tutti
quanti disegni in modo da poter
permettere qua sotto le vostre votazioni
quindi abbiamo disegno numero 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 e 11
fatemi sapere qua sotto quali sono i
vostri preferiti quali vostri quelli che
diciamo non trovate molto carini vivere
con video tutti io ci ho messo del mio
meglio
ve lo giuro ho cercato di farlo nella
maniera più veloce possibile anche
perché poi abbiamo aggiunto certo punto
questa regola del non si può cancellare
che sinceramente non c'era all'inizio
però vabbè questo qui in realtà un
piccolo omaggio a voi che mi seguite
avrei forse potuto rapinarli in casa e
serve sfumare comunque mi piace vedere i
profili delle persone mi seguono che mi
scrivono le storie sin qui vengo taggato
mi piace in generale interagire secondo
questo qui era un modo divertente se
volete seguirmi su instagram guglielmo
scilla
fatemi sapere se vi è piaciuta questo
esperimento potrei di farlo in futuro
mettete di un bel pollice in su per il
se vi è piaciuto questo video
iscrivetevi a questo canale
noi come sempre ci vediamo questa
domenica con una cucina buttata io e la
coperta una nonna vi salutiamo ciao
nonno accaduta reportage